hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the Gibraltar trade wise chess
festival like I said in my previous
video both our engine and Nakamura had
the white pieces in round 9 so it will
be very difficult for them to get paired
in round 10 but in the end that they did
get paired and it's Aragon versus
Nakamura on board one onion got the
white pieces so let's see this game and
the game is interesting from the very
start all the way to the end
Aragon opened with the d4 we have d6 and
now II for transposing it to the Pierce
defense
g6 we have Knight to f3 Knight f6 Knight
to c3 and Bishop to g7 this is the
classical variation of the Pierce Bishop
to e3 Knight to c6 and d5 now Knight
back to bb8 we have Queen d2 preparing
this battery so Bishop can always go to
H 7th which exchange the dark square
bishop so we have c6 Bishop to e2 and we
have castles by nakamura castles by our
onion and c captures on d5 c e captures
on b5 and b6 now Bishop to h6 Bishop to
b7 now Bishop captures King captures and
night to d4 and already we have a very
interesting position can nakamura
capture the pawn on d5 well the short
answer is no why not well because okay
first you don't want to capture with the
bishop because you're simply giving up
your very strong bishop just to drive a
pawn and in the end this loses quite
badly after Knight captures Bishop to f3
you pin tonight and a36 c4 now you win
the exchange Knight has to move in then
Bishop captures rook another thing is if
you play Knight captures on d5 you get
Bishop to f3 immediately and after a 6
now rook to e1 and after Queen to d7 as
the Queen does have to defend the bishop
on b7 1 the knight moves now you play
Knight to b5 Knight to f6 and this is
something you have to play if you play
something like a 6 for example you get
to Knight captures on d5 and after ecaps
are simply Knight back to c3 now black
has doubled pawns and the white will be
to capture well the d5 point and very
quickly the d6 pawn so this would be
very bad for black so after an ID to be
five best move for black is Knight to f6
but then comes Bishop captures Queen
captures and Knight captures on d6
winning back the pawn and white is much
better in development and well a better
position for white so after night to d4
nakamura doesn't capture he plays a6 we
have a four and now Knight B to d7 f4
now grabbing some more space not
allowing this night to jump to d5
and here Nakamura does have a lot of
options he can go maybe Queen to c7
bring the rook to e8 maybe push e5 but
Nakamura decides to play b5 and
sacrifice a pawn so a capture some b5 a
capture some b5 and here Bishop captures
on b5 was played so her name is now up
upon and there was one interesting
variation that they tried during the
live commentary by Simon Williams and
Johan Kokoschka
was Knight captures on b5 with the idea
that after Queen to b6 check King goes
to H 1 and this is X mu this was Simon's
idea and after D captures on e6 now rook
captures on a1 Rock captures and Queen
to have two threatening checkmate and
although this does look very nice
unfortunately it doesn't work for
Nakamura only move is rook to g1
defending and now let's say after Knight
to g4 you can't capture the night or you
lose the Queen and d2 after Knight to g4
you have he captures on b7 and after
Bishop to f3 Queen captures and b6 you
have Queen to h4 now threatening
checkmate
but here white actually wins wins after
Queen captures on f8 King captures and
now d8 with Queen checking the King and
also threatening to capture the Queen on
h4 so black must capture and now of
course not Bishop captures on f3 because
you get nice to have two this is
checkmate as modern mate but you play G
captures and f3 attacking the knight and
after the night
moves let's say Bishop to d3 and White
has a knight of Bishop and the rook for
a queen
also his updo pawns so he definitely has
the compensation and it's a better
position for white so black can't go for
something like this
so after this a capture some b5 Bishop
capture some beef I was played and now
Knight captures on d5 a knight
characters Bishop captures and c4 by
Aaron on Bishop to b7
we have rook 81 and King to g8 Bishop
captures on d7 Queen capture 77 and now
f5 trying to break open the position
trying to create some attacking chances
and white is definitely better here here
nakamura played Queen to c7 either going
for the c4 pawn or if the knight moves
maybe Queen to c6 will be an idea here
Luke to f4 was played and rock to the 4
is a is an excellent move threatening
rook to h4 going for the attack and also
indirectly defending c4 if you capture
you get tonight the e6 attacking the
Queen and the rook on f6 the knight is
defended so this would lose the exchange
so after rook to f4 Queen to b6 was
played by pinning the knight on d4 we
have looked to h4 the threat now is
Queen to h6 threatening Queen to h7
checkmate
so h5 was played and this is the
critical moment of the game here our
onion should have played something like
rope to f4 let's say rook to a2 and
after rook goes back to F to this
unpinch the night and also guards the B
to pawn let's say Queen to a5 now pawn
captures Queen captures pawn captures on
f7 rook captures and rook captures Queen
it's a it's a better position for white
our Aragon would be up upon and you know
the game the game goes on the problem is
after this
h5 moved by Nakamura Aragon played rook
captures on h5 and what's the idea here
well G captures on
h5 was played as Nakamura saw that this
doesn't work
Queen to g5 check King h7 Queen captures
on h5 King back to g8 and now Queen to
g4 check here Nakamura played rocked
King to h7 and this was arrogance plan
all along
the plan was rook to e3 followed by rook
to h3 checkmate unfortunately for him
this doesn't work and this is a very
nice moment for you to pause the video
and see for yourself
why doesn't look III followed by a rope
to h3 work for white
I'll give it a couple seconds as usual
so for those of you who managed to find
congratulations you are a great player
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show the reason why rook to e3
doesn't work is rook to a one-trick now
you have to play King to f2 and now
comes Queen captures on b2 again with
Czech and now if linking to g3 or f3 now
we were blocking your own rook so
there's really no point in doing this if
you play rook to e2 again the rook can
never come to h3 so the only move is
Knight to e2 blocking but now black has
Queen to g7 offering an exchange of
Queens and if rook to h3 is now played
sorry if rope to h3 is played and then
simply King moves back to g8 and always
well and also if you move the Queen now
then Queen captures and g2 is coming so
probably you want to play something like
Queen to h4 check you don't want it
exchange Queens as you're down a whole
rook and after Queen to h6 probably
Queen to e7 Bishop captures and g2 King
captures and Rock to g8 rock blocks and
now Queen to h5 attacking the knight I
need two after rook captures King
captures now you don't really have any
checks you can give one check but after
the King hides there are no more checks
so probably Queenie for and after rook
to a 2 now pinning this Knight is
attacked twice the King can help out
with the defense but then a lot of funds
will be in danger and White has a couple
of more moves before black wins this
game so
unfortunately this wouldn't work so
after this King 2h7 move Iranian gave
one more check Queen to h4 and after
King to g8 they agreed to a draw so this
was quite an important moment in this
game because before this rook captures
on h5 after this h5 move was played like
I said if Aragon continued the game with
something like rook to f4 he could still
continue to play this game for a win as
he's he's much better in this position
there really was no reason to capture on
h5 and it's not like he captured an h5
just to make a quick draw a fourth draw
like you've seen because he really gave
it a lot of thought and he really tried
to make it work you really tried to
calculate rookie 3 huh how could it work
or but unfortunately he missed something
in the calculation I haven't seen the
interview but if if the interview does
pop up I will add it in the description
below so that's the game the game ended
in a draw and as I've heard during the
live commentary there will be four
people playing the tiebreaks air as
there will be at least four people
sharing first place probably a lot more
so I've heard that so far Aaron and
Nakamura MVL and I think Richard report
are the four contenders that will be
playing the tie breaks but if some other
players managed to get victories in the
final round then maybe our onion and MDL
will be kicked kicked off the tie breaks
but we'll see a lot more games to be
played so I will keep you informed
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank and not in Gopala
Gopala Krishna thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon and of
course I forgot as usual you can check
to my previous videos here I think
you'll and I will see you soon